[موسيقى]
إذا كنت هنا من قبل ستلاحظ حدوث
شيء
مرارًا وتكرارًا ، تسخن المياه الحرارية التي تغذي
حب هنغاريا القديم للحب المتناثر
الذي يمكن تتبعه إلى آلاف
السنين ، وهو تاريخ لا يزال من الممكن رؤيته
حتى اليوم
الجياع لديه جيولوجيا فريدة تسمح
للمياه الحرارية العميقة التي يتم تسخينها بواسطة
عباءة الأرض بالانتشار إلى السطح ،
فليس من المستغرب أن نسمع بعد ذلك أن
المجريين كانوا يستفيدون من هذا
منذ آلاف السنين ، ولكن كيف بدأ هذا
الهوس جيدًا؟
قذرة لهذا ، فلنبدأ بالقرب
من البداية في علم سيدجويك ، حيث
يحصلون على الطعام هناك ، كان والدي سايجون
لاتاشا ظل أفيلي على الإطلاق أنا في
البندقية كان يعتقد أن
والدي كان أن الطعام سيضيف تأكيدًا
أنهم دفنوا  طعامهم المفضل الآن ،
دعنا نتخطى بضعة قرون ،
هذا الديك الرومي من خلال المنتجع الصحي الذي تم بناؤه
عام 1571 ، لدينا ستة حافلات مختلفة
تسمى 11 درجة مئوية ، نحن 30 a 33
a 36 و 40 إلى
إنها مروحة  شعور
رائع للاستفادة من القرن السادس عشر ،
تسخين الأنوار على البخار ، وأعتقد أنه
فريد من نوعه ، وأخيراً إلى وقت أصبح
مألوفًا بعد فترة طويلة من المنطقة التركية ، فإن
سلسلة البحر التي تم حفرها في عباس في عام 1918
هي في الوقت الحاضر واحدة من أكبر
مجمعات التمثال في  أوروبا تحت هنغاريا 75٪
مياه حرارية تأتي على عمق كبير
من الأرض لمسافة تزيد عن 1000 متر ولدينا
حمامات سباحة والمصطلح يعارض
بعض الجهد قد يذهب للرئتين فقط لشم
رائحته إذا كان لديك بعض مشكلة
الاسترخاء هنا لمدة ثلاث ساعات
ستشعر بتحسن أفضل وأن كل منزل جماعي
له طابعه الخاص
ورائحته ومشاعره الخاصة. إنه
لأمر مدهش
أنت
[موسيقى]